alright guys well thanks for inviting me
to your amazing office thank you so so
what do you guys make so we are app deco
abductor is a marketplace for buying and
selling furniture based here in New York
City we take care of essentially like
the whole process from picking up and
delivery to payments and everything in
between
yeah so basically we kind of took
Craigslist and just you know said we get
a trusted community of users if you can
make the pickup and delivery easy
between two people and the payments
between two people you'd have something
useful and so that's essentially been
the premise since we launched and what
what made you convinced that this could
be a fully fledged product because I've
seen all kinds of blog posts about like
you know the fragmentation of Craigslist
right in some if it's succeeded as
products and others haven't what gave
you the impression that this could be a
thing well I mean we started out of our
own frustration yeah just having a
really bad experience trying to sell on
furniture on Craigslist but realizing
it's a big opportunity was we did a lot
of market research to sort of test if
this is something that people would
would be interested in sort of the
premise of the solution so for example
we would go on Craigslist initially and
test hey with delivery like we'll
actually just copy somebody's listing
and just add delivery and see how people
react to it and we saw that like oh this
is there's definitely a big opportunity
there because people seem to be a lot
more responsible when you just add the
delivery like word to the listing how
could you know that if you hadn't
created the original listing would you
see you would do pit ways yeah you would
do one with in one with exactly okay
yeah it will I think we when we did our
research we saw was the fifth most
popular category on Craigslist for
furniture was the fifth most fifth most
popular category and then when we we
created like an MVP and
and when we actually had launched the
site the first day that we had the
Frankenstein of a site in 2014 you know
we we had a transaction the day that we
launched and this is with no earthly
idea of like really what we were doing
you know I just think all those signs
kind of pointed to it and then when we
apply to YC and ultimately got into YC I
think that's when we were like you know
[ __ ] this is this is real you know yeah
were you pursuing other potential ideas
because yeah like the market research
thing is much more of the business
school approach and it's a less common
approach within YC startups right so
where were there other ideas that you
were considering there wasn't any other
ideas and you know I just Muhammad I
don't want it to work together for a
long period of time yeah and you know
quite frankly it wasn't really that
scientific and we weren't I don't think
we're the traditional founders in the
sense that you know we we were in like
serial entrepreneurs we you know come
from very traditional business
background but we were like you know we
took a light inspiration from Airbnb and
other companies right this is this seems
very obvious yeah
and that we kind of just took it and ran
with it yeah I mean I think I think for
us like our experience like we were so
frustrated with what happened to us when
we were trying to sell our furniture on
Craigslist and we started kind of really
frankly obsessing over like this just
through is really really bad that I
frankly I don't think either one of us
was ready at the time to start a
business but we stumble upon this idea
when you are ending business school
ending business school and column it was
sort of like happened all at the same
time I was ending I was finishing
Business School coming back to the city
to start a job at a startup not start my
own company and so I was trying to sell
my furniture and I just had a really
really bad experience and column at the
same time was also trying to sell a
piece of sofa sofa and whose also had a
bad experience and so we were just like
talking about it and just like
why is so bad everybody had just taken
off uber had just taken off and you know
everybody is like now doing this sort of
quote-unquote sharing economy so why
couldn't you do that with furniture and
we just kept on talking about it all the
time to the extent where like hey like
let's just do this yeah you know now
it's the time we don't need more
experience so and that's that's really
kind of how we happen though say yeah
how did you psychologically prepare
yourself to like go off that ledge and
not have the steady
you know goldman paycheck you also from
business I think that we were just kind
of at the point where you know I think
when we had kind of gotten to the
interview point of you know of YC and I
quite frankly I was still kind of
moonlighting so I was still doing my I
was like doing this and there's
something in the evening and then doing
working at L'Oreal and that you know
that's the only job I had ever had I
never worked professionally anywhere
else so I you know so it was how they
know I was very quite frankly very happy
at L'Oreal it wasn't like I was you know
I'd always had like upper mobility and I
loved working there I loved what I was
doing I was very happy yeah in that
corporate environment and you know I had
a lot of experience and upward
trajectory but you know I think that you
know we just saw this as an opportunity
and then we said you know at the end of
the day like if we failed you know it's
not like we couldn't go back to you know
corporate America or go somewhere else
and we always were kind of confident or
in our skills but but this is super
interesting to me because I hundred
percent agree with you and I think
that's true for most people at these
super competitive jobs they're talented
enough to get the job they could get it
again yeah but how you flip that switch
to get over the fear you know I think
when we got into Y Combinator that's we
were just like okay so when we got to
the interview point yeah
then we were just like okay where we're
gonna why sieve we got to do it I mean
like the he already quit before like he
had already given his note column
his notice before we even got to we had
received an interview request but we
hadn't been to icy yet for the interview
didn't so he were in so we didn't know
we're in but I had already I decided not
to take the job that it came to New York
for and ended up just doing this
full-time yeah
and column was moonlighting and
essentially helped financing it so while
you know while he was working at L'Oreal
and then doing this at night and
weekends but you know I think I mean I
think like we just saw a problem that we
became very intimate with and also the
solution for the problem we experienced
it during the same time so you know when
we had this really bad experience um
trying to sell her furniture on
Craigslist I was I moved back to New
York and I had my truck and a column
borrowed my truck for that one day we
listed it on listed back his listening
on Craigslist saying one day only free
delivery in New York City and that same
day someone gave him the full amount and
showed up immediately did not cancel did
not flake was not sketchy and so we're
like wow like this is this is how you do
it you have to offer a delivery you have
to take care of everything you have to
make it simple and so we saw the
solution and that like really helped us
sort of it fast forwarded our I guess
our like process of deciding whether we
should do this or not because we we had
the problem and the solution at the same
time and we're like okay we got to do it
right so you have that kind of like
positive feedback yeah yeah I guess and
I guess we just felt it was a good kind
of common-sense solution as well yeah I
think it sounds like we're very we're
probably more practical than most yeah
and we're probably you know we're
probably kind of one foot in front of
the other type of founders yeah versus
you know like you know I don't know like
kind of in the clouds
we're very yeah yeah we're very I think
we're very practical in the sense um and
I think that we saw this is a very
seeing in with our own eyes and seeing
the opportunity we thought of it as very
practical kind of solution to something
that you know everybody else furniture
it's a kind of big problem so I
a lot of those kind of things were you
know kind of fit I think within our if I
have to think it back back about it now
food within our wool house like this is
very something very tangible and
something that could be really useful
and you could kind of model it out yeah
oh this works yeah this works absolutely
and had it and then how did you
communicate that to your friends and
family from these like prestigious jobs
and schools and so we're still figuring
that out yeah you know it's funny like
the first time I actually sat down with
um what my father and you know I we've
been counting these conversations with
investors recently so I show them like
our investor deck and I'm just kinda
just done through the investor deck and
I'm like you know and it's such a
strange thing to talk about you know
raising a few million dollars or doing
this and that it just you know it a lot
of times are quite frankly I think it's
just like you know you're talking I mean
it's it's very hard to make it very
tangible you know for you know we're
saying we're practical there uber
practical you know so but I think that
they understood it I think when we when
we first did this back in 2014 I think
there's a lot of um I wouldn't say just
skepticism I think was just like worried
mmm just worried you know I don't give
up like that good job and don't you know
though you know a bird in the hand a
bird in the hand is definitely I think
the philosophy that my parents have and
then climb most people pilot that
generation and I would guess and rahama
class speak on it you know they're you
know we speak on that is that you know
they're you know you if you're having a
meritorious like you know you're gonna
you find a good job at a good company
and you'd stay there and so this is I
think was just so foreign yeah they were
skeptical and worried but at the same
time kind of supportive yeah I'm a
parent so I'm I'm from Sudan I came to
the US for college and so my parents
still live in sedan so for them the
golden ticket is to have a job at
Goldman and I not start a company and
you know just work crazy hours and the
whole thing has just kind of been crazy
for them so they're like finally think
wrapping their heads around it but I
mean pretty much almost a referral
all I have when my parents is like so
what is this going to be over yeah it's
just it's also they don't live here so
they don't see the impact we're making
you know like they it's a completely
different world right for them so so
they just don't really understand it but
they're supportive which is the
important part you know so there's not a
kind of an entrepreneurship narrative in
Sudan oh it's huge my dad has his own
business my my entire family yeah all my
family members have their own businesses
because the the way the economy
structured there is there's no large
corporations
and now I guess there's a couple but
most people are just small business
owners you know my dad has his own
engineering firm my aunts and uncles
most of them have you know either like
their own medical practice or
engineering firms or architecture firms
or what have you so that's the the norm
but I guess because probably their
business owners that they know is how
hard it is to run a business like if you
have a job that pays well and you don't
have to worry about you know covering
everybody else's salary why are you
doing this to yourself so that's
probably where it comes from I actually
think you know a my my parents are
probably you know even working at
L'Oreal was like a kind of a leap for
them you know they're more like like a
good stable government type of job wait
where are you from I'm from California
Oh from the Bay Area and so I think that
you know they're like uber focused on
stability you know and so we're even
though that's you know I was never
interested in those but you know
particular type of things I was always
interested in business and wanted to
work in a company I was exciting and
innovative it even for them I think that
kind of seemed like kind of like fluff
and so this was like even another level
of generational thing cuz you would
assume that even like being from
California at least says like oh you go
work at HP or something yeah that's not
yeah you know didn't your dad work in
the government or he did yeah he did he
did and so and my mom worked for like
the railroad I've got some in specifics
I think you know super stable scary
snakes exactly super stable so even a
company like L'Oreal or Goldman
Saxe that that goldman sexto has a
process where they laid all I think
tempered their bottom tempers in every
year or some really right you know so
and morals of extremely lean you know
company or corporation so it's it's not
a company where you can like hide around
and yeah schema house you can't get a
host you know and so what's that's thing
that has never been the type of thing
that I was interested in anyway okay you
know and did you go to business school
as well I didn't either no I went to
undergrad at Clark Atlanta okay which is
historically black college in Atlanta
Georgia and were crack our crew for
l'oréal right out of undergrad and I was
there for like 13 years no kidding yeah
okay and now how do you get in were you
getting into startups in Business School
like how did this happen amongst your
friends because I know that that's been
a pretty big shift from like you know 15
years ago if you went to HBS it was like
private equity or like consulting right
but now it seems like more people are
going to like you know like the Google
is in the Facebook type companies right
so when you were in school was that
coming up or yes
yes it was definitely coming up sort of
there was definitely a shift were more I
went to Wharton and there were more my
class or more people talking about tech
yeah versus going into banking and
finance so like the market had crashed a
few years before and you know a lot of
people are just sort of exhausted from
the financial industry and they were
looking for something else was actually
interesting when I started Business
School I mean I knew I was always gonna
do something actually my one of my
essays was about building a social
enterprise but I didn't know what kind
of social enterprise I always thought it
would be connected to Sudan or connect
moved to Africa in a way but I always
knew that I was going to start something
at some point but I didn't think
straight out of business school I'm
ready I needed more experience and
that's why I wanted to join a startup so
when I was at business school I saw this
shift where a lot of people were asking
me questions people who came from finest
about tack because I'm an engineer and
everybody wanted to like okay well you
know tell me more about tech and like
you know how do you be a product manager
how do you do this on the Queen a minute
all these people are active and I'm
trying to get out of you know tech
something is wrong there and so you know
I really started digging deeper and but
I did definitely do a lot of startup
sort of business plan competitions when
I was in business school okay um talked
to a lot of people who started their own
businesses and just sort of realize
about all these people are I mean I feel
like I'm smarter than as smart as them
they can do it I should be able to do it
and that really helped me and I think at
Bridgette I was you know I think we were
very as they're fortunate to for Mihama
to kind of work on this work on that
deco kind of at that time because she
was being immersed - mm-hmm kind of the
startup world where I think I was quite
for anything like very removed from it
when I think about come where we are now
and I think about 3yc versus pulse YC
you know and just this the just the tech
environment particularly in the Bay Area
- sure you know we're like man I was
light years away from that particular
world and if it wasn't for at Y
Combinator kind of giving us like a
significant immersion into kind of the
startup world I don't think that you
know we I don't think we wouldn't have
we would have had the progress that
we've had like definitely not because
there's there's so many things that you
know I think when we started as we said
unless we have a lot of business
experience yeah we work at great
companies we've worked we've worked at
great companies we can just apply that
knowledge and and and start this company
and this is the furthest thing from the
truth I mean we you know just what it
takes to get from zero to ten you know
as is a totally different zero hundreds
a totally different skill set then than
what we had acquired during our
professional years
what were the the outstanding learnings
from a classical business education
because I think there's like this common
trope that like business school is a
waste of time and even like business
education in a lot of the startup
culture right and so people fall back on
you know whether it's like PJ's essays
or kind of like Lean Startup things but
I'd be willing to bet that there were
super valuable courses that you guys
took and so if you were talking to other
startup founders well what would you
pressure them to learn I mean one of the
things that I always think and I always
joke up the team about is financial
modeling and just being able you know
I've become pretty crazy with is not
even financial model but just modeling
how do you model how do you build
projections how do you think about
business scenarios and you know sort of
as you think about your next big project
yeah like how do you map that out that
was purely from business school I think
that's like probably the biggest thing
that I still use every day here yeah I
think for me just analytical structure
so when you're how how to structure
looking at numbers in a way that makes
sense you know I mean that's all I did
it L'Oreal I did in my whole my whole
entire preferable career and so you know
at first yeah it was not as applicable
like so you know when you're first
giving first a beginning start off on
the ground you just got to like just do
[ __ ] and go and see what sticks and then
do more of it and then listen you can
analyze it like later down a lot like at
first it's just like you just got to do
a whole bunch of stuff not in a scalable
manageable way you're doing the delivery
result on your own - yeah yeah we were
doing deliveries we're going to people's
homes buying furniture like we're doing
all kind of crazy stuff you know and you
know have the instruction of other YC
partners and then you figure out how to
take those kind of crazy zany ideas and
to make them into kind of scalable
practical models yeah things that are
repeatable in a scalable way so but
after that once you after you do that
you know you have to know how to view
analytics set up you know a strong
foundation to really be able to look and
say did this work that that work how do
I continue to repeat this the other
things too is I think is um that people
don't talk about enough is just just the
establishing a business culture how to
team management people management huge
and that's a huge pitfall for first
startups is that they don't know how to
manage people they have a lot you know
they they implode because you know
because they don't know how to do a
conflation culture they don't yeah they
don't know how to talk to one another
they don't know how to you know manage
dynamics if there's if there's conflict
one month one another and
I think I think that's why one of the
biggest things that people don't talk
about enough is just you know conflict
management and in in in people
management is something that I think
that we've been able to deal with hiring
firing all those things or things that
we've had experience with that that are
very tangible and very relatable to
start off and like even creating
structure I would say so you know early
on sure your tiny team maybe you're like
three or four people and people sort of
dismissed the idea oh we don't really
need structure we can just talk to each
other all the time
but having regular checkpoints like
weekly meetings and you know those type
of things actually make a big difference
or big difference or even you know team
meetings where everyone comes together
and talk about so whatever's happening
next week or what have you people
dismiss that and these are the things
that come from business school come from
sort of our traditional work experience
that do those things that we've done
every day when we were there right and
so we've been able to steal that from an
early early early on and in sort of our
business and I think it really helped
help sort of calm things down mm-hmm to
some extent because it's crazy being in
a start-up anyway so if you can create a
bit of sense of stability stability it
goes a long way for the rest of the team
yeah how would you structure that say if
I under approached you and like this is
how you should structure your check-ins
or whatever it might be
what's up what's the framework you use
we meet we meet with our direct reports
once a week and more if we need if need
be but once a week to just to talk
through just what are the kind of the
strategic projects that they're working
on we just have our project list sheet
that's public for everyone to see so we
were president of project lead sheets in
Google sheets simple stupid and we have
all of our strategic projects that
people are working on we touch on those
projects and we have kind of tentative
due dates sometimes you know they'll
finish ahead sometimes it'll take longer
it's more than you expected and we have
those we also have daily stand-up
meetings where we just have a quick kind
of touch touch base in regards to what
we're working on to keep the team
kind of engage in collaborative and then
we have a one one one time a week teen
KPI meeting or event we review the
overarching numbers for the company okay
so that could be said you know sales
dollar sales refunds returns positive
and negative Yelp reviews you know all
those things so we have about once a
week and when it comes to conflict and
well actually just dealing with conflict
not conflict avoidance like how do you
do is that through the one-on-ones yeah
mm-hmm that's through the one-on-ones
and we've also done we do performance
reviews even in our state so we've been
doing them for the last three we've been
around for almost five years but we've
been doing them for probably three this
is our third or fourth time it's very
simple like we didn't use a software or
anything we just created some questions
on you know time which are what you know
how how do you rate this person's
ability to deal with difficult
situations or you know their
problem-solving skills or teen
management skills or responsible
responsiveness things like that like I
think they're like 10 or 15 question is
it quantitative yeah so it's a scale one
to five okay and it's 360 so so
everybody reviews every I want to use
every 150 people review fifty no no so
this is our the HQ team so ten ten
people yeah exactly
and it doesn't take long
yeah and then we review it and then even
column and I hours are public so the
whole team gets to see because we have
to hold ourselves accountable as well so
we find you know transparency is very
important so we share with them now are
those anonymous yes sir
very important yeah that's tricky yes
yeah that's tricky and so we compile the
feedback um you know of course like when
you're writing written feedback there's
sometimes you can tell who's who
but B as the managers we compile the
feedback and try to anonymize it as much
as possible but the form itself is
definitely not anonymous as well yeah
but you know I think the one thing that
I
you know that just to kind of harp on
that again that can't be I think it's
important to stresses just you know how
we're not afraid to in a very you know
and obviously you know in a way that's
developmental afraid to tell people when
they're not meeting a particular
expectation or falling below but to be
able to do it in a way that's very
constructive and I know that's just I
know that's from from working in
corporate America where you have to be
politically correct and you have to know
how to kind of structure feedback in a
way that you know in a way that is that
works for a company of that scale and I
see a lot of stunners struggle with that
I see a lot of them struggle with that
and they'll just let something fester on
and on because they don't know the you
know because they're not they haven't
had kind of a professional training in a
conflict manager for sure yeah I mean
have you guys had to let people go at
this point yeah yes yeah yeah so what do
you think founders get wrong in that
department and I think we've fallen
victim this they way too long yeah they
they are not transparent in terms of
like maybe they'll fire them at without
really giving them the opportunity to
course-correct
yeah so though they'll bill as a manager
they'll bottle in like I'm so tired with
this person doing XYZ and they'll just
hold it in for six months and then
they'll just feel like you know 5x well
and this is first of all a I didn't even
know I was doing something wrong yeah
you know so I think those are kind of
things that you know I think those are
some things that people definitely kind
of amidst us yeah I mean I think those
are like definitely get to and we always
if it's performance related because
sometimes you're firing because
quote-unquote you're downsizing or maybe
the role no longer is needed yeah yeah I
mean even like if you're changing
direction engaging that person earlier
on the conversation yeah so they
understand like hey and we've actually
had to do that hey like this is where
the company's headed it looks like we
don't need this role anymore why don't
we put plan together to see if there's
something else you can do if there isn't
then you know start looking for
something else and we're giving them
that opportunity and being that
transparent actually
yeah what's really really it's very hard
conversation to have sure but it's an
important conversation because these are
you know like people that we really care
about we want them to to also be
successful but in terms of farming
firing in terms of performance we always
talk about also by the time you're fired
you should know that you're kind of
getting from kids it's not you know it's
coming because we've had plenty of
conversations about performance about
expectations about you not meeting
expectations if it's the shock that
means as a manager you're doing
something wrong yeah if they're
surprised that it that means you're
doing something wrong mm-hmm and when it
came to modeling about your product in
the early days in the beginning did you
ever have negative margins yes yeah yeah
I'm doing we yeah I mean we also did not
really we've had to learn what our March
did like how do you actually compute
your margins and what goes in all the
different you know to lift the nuance of
the transaction it took us time to learn
that all right so I mean even like her
fees was just so low we were charging I
think it was like ten to fifteen percent
transaction fee versus now it's like
nineteen to twenty nine percent
yeah and that's because we were not
really thinking about margin at all at
the time which is I think like a lot of
the issues or yeah or we just you know
we you know we weren't we thought we
knew the cost but they need you don't
you but once you get into it you realize
there are a business cost here cost
there and so you know the model is just
kind of the foundation and structure but
for sure it's gonna change and once you
really get into it that's why I think YC
is so good just about like I mean you
just gotta do it just do it because
you're there's so many things that I
mean I look her how many amazing models
you have how much experience you have
there's when you do over the first time
there's gonna be some things that you're
gonna uncover that you weren't expecting
and you gotta be able to you know modify
and change for that I think also like
early on you can't like you have to
can't be optimizing just yet for margins
yeah but you know it doesn't mean that
you offer your products for free because
you still don't know what goes into it
into it like what are the different
variables but once you've established
that hey like this is actually a product
that works
people wanted and then come back then
you need to look to get into the data
and figure out exactly what it takes to
make a transaction how much it costs to
get a customer all those things and then
adjust your fees and prices accordingly
yeah yeah cuz I was wondering you would
mentioned in another podcast about
partnering up with another delivery
provider early on right so I assume this
is you guys are doing it in the very
beginning right because you're like
we're gonna test if this is a product
that anyone gives a [ __ ] about and then
you're like okay getting this like going
in the direction of product market fit
but how do you even figure it out that
pricing like our did you just guess that
people weren't gonna be price sensitive
and add an extra 10% on like so when we
work with the moving company we just
negotiated the lowest price we could
negotiate yeah and then it definitely
did not work out because you know they
ended up canceling a lot of our jobs
because they get more expensive jobs and
our customers were getting upset so then
we brought it in-house and we were just
we probably kept it at the same price
initially yeah and I definitely at that
point was negative margins then we
actually ran a be testing in terms of
pricing to understand prices sensitivity
and that helped us determine like what
is the reader to threshold for what
people are willing to pay versus it's
kind of like a formula you can sell more
products mmm and lower delivery fees and
maybe your fees will cover the
difference yeah or you sell less
products and higher delivery fees right
and so like we fear we finally
understand what is the right mix yeah to
make it work and do you think that sweet
spot is the same across cities no I
don't think it would be the same but
they'll have to wait in yes see yes you
read it yeah TPD bad New York is I think
I think in New York because people don't
have cars yeah um it's much harder right
and so people are probably willing to
pay I would venture to guess a bit more
for delivery than in other cities and
maybe in other cities people are willing
to pick up things on their own more
frequently but you I mean I when I lived
here very few I mean like
like I could count on one hand my
friends who had cars let alone a truck
and you know what you do anyone any
friend with a car you're always like oh
this is the friend like when you're
going to the Hamptons take me with you
or if you're going to Ikea please let me
know right so yeah those friends are
always very yeah and as you guys have a
aged now do you have you gone upmarket
or
like who are your average customers at
this point so the average customer the
the seller and the buyer Sider are
different so we got kind of two
different customer bases so the seller
is a little bit older so let's say
they're like 30 to 55 and you know maybe
they're they're you know stereotypically
they're like Mary maybe they're like
making room for a baby they have higher
disposable income and you know for
people listening work on in the New York
area let's just say they're like the
Upper West Side couple if you can
imagine that and then the buyer is
Williamsburg 25 to mid-30s first a
second job first or second job and so
you know they are aspirational so
they're you know maybe they were buying
IKEA but F decals an outlet for them to
now kind of get West Elm or Restoration
Hardware or Crate and Barrel and get
these really really Design Within Reach
is really kind of nice brands from these
higher-end people and higher in customer
base and so we kind of have these two
kind of parties that were kind of
matching together I think quite nicely
yeah
and then in terms of your question about
upmarket
we are do we do we're starting to see a
shift where people are like seller there
are more sellers who are becoming buyers
for example which is for us it's a great
indicator that we are also changing the
way people shop used it is important for
us so you know if you have a higher
disposable income you probably you can
go you can afford to go just by the
research and harder
peace again but you're willing to come
back to app deco and shop for for the
same research and hardware piece at 50%
off because you're you know select for
us that's like a very big indicator
mm-hmm
we're we're definitely sort of raising
widening the age gap I think for like
the buyer side and the seller side is
much easier because even if any buyer
who sell buys through us ends up selling
through us anyway when when your time is
right but seeing that shift from for the
seller side for them to become buyers
it's really big for us and what
percentage of the sales are driven by
like big brands like how much of the
stuff is like you know Design Within
Reach Restoration Hardware type stuff as
a percentage on your site yeah so around
65 70 percent or the top 7 brands here
Louis so huge IKEA
what's down cb2 creme barrel room board
in New York ABC carpenter home you see
the agency carpet at home so you know
for us like that was this that would
know that this whole kind of
understanding of brands was a big aha
moment for us yeah you know from an
acquisition perspective from a merchant
and you know site merchandising
perspective that you know that these are
the things that the levers that drive
acquisition and drive how we should be
presenting and speaking to the site
because you know these are things that
kind of speak to it's the easiest way to
derive quality is through is through
brand right well and I would also
imagine that's like a ton of organic
search like people are looking for
Restoration Hardware couch exactly and
like that's exactly yeah exactly and how
I'll see you guys are acquiring
customers at this point so we acquire
customers through Facebook Instagram
Google our original channel we kind of
did this backwards our first channel
that we're able to figure out how was
actually out of home civil advertising
here in New York City so which is
totally backwards and so you know
definitely not the traditional I think
advertising would first start us but I
think you know my experience that
with kind of out of out of home or TV
advertising all those things I think it
kind of lend ourself to kind of go there
and then we have to figure out the
digital part after so actually can I
think speaks to kind of I think quite
frankly our shortcomings from a
acquisition perspective the things that
we have to kind of learn is we went
along but now we've had the time to kind
of really figure these things out but
yeah so now we have a really diverse
group with the majority of our customers
now they're through through referral not
only 45 50 percent of our customers are
through word about friends and family
type stuff and so which is you know
something we're very excited about
that's with yeah how do you track a
subway ID did you have a unique URL like
I can't imagine people remember that we
also asked people how they've heard
about us like at checkout order hosting
okay yeah it wasn't it wasn't the coupon
cuz no one you know nobody nobody used
it it was just when we launched it to uh
support it I mean our our um I'm Eric
triple yeah after we get to see it cuz I
was at the only channel this is only
challenge very and then we'd asked you
know when people were either listening
at piece of furniture or buying piece of
furniture like Rohan mentioned how do
you hear about us and I mean it was very
extremely obvious and it also this is
like a shot offer African Subway
advertising but it also had a nice halo
effect for our other channels as well so
that's like a validator yeah all this
comfort like people have always assumed
that were much larger than we cut
because of subway advertising no doubt
did you do that with a YC money like how
much did you have in the bank when you
spent all that on Subway average it was
a risk it was a risk
yeah definitely less than 500 K yeah
yeah yeah that's a big chunk yeah
50k for just one you know one one one
month at one month of how many cars one
there's 6,000 subway cars in New York
City and we were in one in six wanted
say with one add in those subway yes so
now oh you can't even like a B and dad
you can't print a bunch of random ones
one and and you know at the time I was
very confident and I was like I was
crazy we were I hired them we hired a
guy that a creative executive lore'l
that I used to work with and had a great
rapport with and we hired him and we
still work with him I'm like mom yeah no
can be testing did it we came up a
concept and then he he makes it look
amazing yeah we were literally I kind of
bursting at the seams but from the
response cuz we didn't have we didn't
have the you know back in kind of we
didn't have the delivery operation to
some work on them yeah kind of the
growth that we had at that time so
that's what I also wanted to ask you
about cuz that that delivery operation
seems daunting for a lot of people so I
did you hire someone with experience and
that are you just like wing it
we definitely winged it yeah yeah so
that was quite a lesson learned and I
think we probably could have benefited
from hiring someone with experience
earlier on I would say yeah but we yeah
we didn't know what we're doing frankly
we didn't know what we were doing we
were just we were you know it was like
2014 15 were bursting at the seams we
just needed to fulfill orders and we
were just renting vans we were not
thinking about margins we were not
thinking about how much it's costing to
do any of that
we ended up leasing long-term leases I
think what eight or nine vans at the
time was definitely premature because
you our business is cyclical or seasonal
excuse me so so we didn't really think
about what happens during the low season
and then all these vans were just parked
in the Train in the parking lot but
we've learned a ton since then and we
now have our head operations who
actually comes from furniture
manufacturing supply chain she's done a
lot of this type of operation so she's
helped us a lot together at the same
time I think that I mean it's from a
from like a text from a text Acker from
an intellectual property standpoint you
know what we've built on the operation
side
the way that our model works is so we
don't we don't warehouse anything so we
only we pick it up and deliver it in the
same time doing hundreds of pickups and
deliveries across three states and so
near the scheduling of these two people
across you know across you know all
these variables is very complex and I
think that that required some kind of
you know a little bit of outside of the
box thinking in order to be able to do
that so you know what we've build is
really unique and I imagine that
building it from scratch and not having
any preconceived notions in regards to
how delivery and logistics works in some
ways was helpful because it allowed us
to kind of imagine something that I
think is really different than what
anybody is doing yeah
and that's and that's why you know our
our model is you know it's one that's as
compared to other kind of furniture
consignment models is a lot more
lightweight and a lot has the ability to
kind of scale cuz we don't have these
type of costs because we would imagine
something really interesting from a
delivery sample yeah so you there's no
like kind of open source routing
software that you're using you just kind
of rolled your own for it we definitely
looked yeah no we ended up building
everything ourselves so okay and so are
you a CS engineer call electrolytic so
how are you vetting these engineers in
the early days I mean in the early days
our team was still very small so but I
mean I did a lot of software development
Goldman so when I was at Goldman in the
beginning that's what I was doing then I
moved to product management and I ran a
team of engineers so so I I knew how to
do that part yeah yeah that was possible
yeah all right and then what about the
the choice to actually not warehouse was
that obvious from the beginning it was
that was always the plan we never
considered warehousing certain it was
warehousing was not the obvious solution
for us because we we always thought that
you're gonna be capped by this
space of it exactly uh you know it's
kind of like like if you use the air B&B
example like building hotels versus
making everybody's apartment a hotel
yeah and so you know we always not that
we knew that like we didn't think about
it like that time though our model
essentially is you can make every
person's home your house pretty much and
so but from the beginning we you know we
were essentially trying to solve the
Craigslist issue which is you go to
somebody's house and you pick it up from
them and you pay them in cash and then
so why don't you just do that by paying
them online and then somebody else picks
it up for you yeah and so the
warehousing parties never point of
consideration it was not apparent yeah
now for other reasons realize you know
it's just it's cost prohibitive yeah you
can't you can't
in our opinion build a build a business
model a sustainable business model by
having by warehousing everything because
you can always gonna be capped by the
space the cost to cover it someone is
going to have to pay for it and
ultimately to either be the buyer that
selling the platform who was already
relatively price sensitive is a million
reasons why why in our opinion it it
doesn't work and they're in there a lot
of there's been a lot of startups that
have come and gone that have tried to do
it that way and weren't successful
were there other ideas that you thought
might work and then just absolutely
failed that you've tried out Decco
itself yeah you're like features oh yes
plenty what did we try there's so many
the road of any start was lying with the
gazillion failures so we actually did so
you know simple things that intuitively
would actually should work offering
photograph for graphing for customers
yeah nobody wants to do that so funny so
yeah if you took the Airbnb advice and
you're like this was a huge growth thing
for you yeah this is obviously gonna
work for us nope doesn't work did not
work
offering cleaning
services and all that type of stuff nope
did not work who don't care people don't
care they don't wanna pay for it
I mean yeah but if they don't want to
pay for it it's also super really
discounted so if you go to the same
company to do the cleaning
they'll pay they'll charge a double we
were we we negotiated very good con like
very good deals and people were not
buying them so we couldn't even keep the
deals because we you know promised a
certain number of cleaning jobs so you
know stuff like that there's kind of
this stuff stuff that you think should
work did not
people were not budging okay you know
they're interesting interesting thing
too is that you know there there are
things that you think they'd work and
they don't work and then you do them
again and they do work so for example
you know we were mentioning the
acquisition channels and now we're doing
Facebook and Instagram advertising today
it is one of our biggest channel
advertising channels and we trot we
hired a agency to manage manage our
campaigns before and they were not
successful when we hire this agency to
do it well we tried we it yeah we were
nice as women we have the evidence II do
it and so then a year later so we're
doing any advertising on adderall a year
later we dust it off and we're like
let's just like look through this and
see if there's something to be learned
from what happened when we tried to do
these that we you to use these
acquisition channels and then we saw one
campaign that campaign did really well
all its 15 campaigns there see one that
did really well let's just turn back on
that campaign let's just see what
happens and then back we turn it back on
its continued to do well why did this
and then then that just kind of spurred
us really understanding our digital
advertising channels that was really the
birth of it yeah torture' now it's it's
it's our one of them it's our most
profitable best channel and you know
it's something that it took us quite
frankly three four years to kind of
really figure out how to do it you know
and so you're sometimes I'm like kicking
myself like how I wish I know and I know
now and you know but it takes that I
think a difficult thing was
startups is you know just it takes some
time to take some time it takes time to
figure things out you know some things
you have to figure out quicker faster or
some things you know you really got a
you know have some patience and one of
our models now models now is you know
particularly from a marketing
perspective is I just rather do a few
things really really exhaustively well
then just try to do a whole bunch of
things to where I can't really
understand the nuance and the detail of
it to understand if it works or not and
yeah I think that's kind of a big shift
that's really paid off
it's also so hard with algorithms anyway
to figure out what you're doing well
yeah I do do you know what was it about
that particular campaign was it the
audience was it the content it was a
content it was um it was an ad that was
testimonial and you know when I look
back actually in all most campaigns I'm
a little embarrassed by this with you
but this one was kind of testimony so I
just spoke at it just like had quotes
from customers if I'm remembering
correctly and that did really well
and the other ones were really off based
when I think about them now in terms of
their performance and the things we were
throwing but you throw things up to have
them stick but then we start doing
things that focus on brands and doing
things like that we start really looking
at our kind of maternal numbers yeah
internal search terms and once you start
becoming really understanding your
digital channels understanding your
search volume your landing pages your
click-through rates and if you
understand those things to say whether
it's for your website you can just kind
of flip it on this header your
advertising and acquisition channels but
it took us some time to really kind of
understand that type of detail mhm yeah
so what kind of analytics are you
running on your site now in terms of
like tracking yeah yeah so we we we
track everything from like clicks to
even usability we record videos like in
the background we track all our data
customer data all of that and we have
visualization tools that we use to
visualize it and be able to manipulate
it and they've been it's been incredible
like since we've invested we've invested
in like one platform specifically and
that has completely like transformed the
way we do things because before we were
running sequel queries right and so like
that takes time so not everybody
actually at some point everybody in our
team knew how to do sequel but but it
takes time you pull it and then you have
to manipulate it you have to analyze it
and then being able to just use a tool
it'd be expensive it made a big big
difference mmhmm yeah this is a reason
why not much man
not I don't want to like advertise it I
guess okay no free shoutouts yeah let's
just say it was his tool is called
looker okay yeah and it's a yeah it's I
mean that was a super helpful that was
great it was a big it was a big change
it I mean I think that that kind of
opened I think kind of opened our up
open its up to more analytics in other
ways
yeah it may be the moment for analytical
company kind of brought us home tore our
experience or professional experience
before starting an app deco to be quite
honest with you this for me please for
me just like able to dig into a lot of
detail that it was hard to catch when
you fear just manipulating Excel
documents before so you know like
getting to like do neurons have brands
by category and the time it takes to
sell and who are these people who Orden
of people are dropping off and why and
what did they have in their card and
yeah and you visualize it all together
so like you have these crazy dashboards
that can be super detailed then you can
actually look at this data and able to
make some sort of look at trends and
make some conclusions and actually able
to use it for marketing purposes or for
updating the product or operations even
the operations we've become a lot
smarter even from our eunuch and IMAX
perspective because we're able to like
look at all the nuance that goes into
making a transaction right so oh okay
this is the revenue but here's all the
costs associated with it and like you
can see that all together it makes a big
difference especially for product people
know did you guys do the New York City
back and forth during YC yes you did
well yes definitely was worth it
so we didn't know that this is what we
were supposed to do so we had like
rented out our apartments here and
subletted apartments and we should we
went to Mountain View and I think I came
over it was like PG or in speech it was
PG he's like what do you first day he's
like what are you guys doing here you
need to be in New York so and so were
like okay and so we started flying back
and forth every week for the three
months yeah it was pretty it was flying
Tuesday morning and then out Wednesday
yeah yeah Wednesday hoot every we ever
ate at laughter Doubleday we like we
crash for like two three days like we
really like yeah after then one day we
wrote because in a date during YC they
attempted talking about talk to your
customers talk to your customers and
we're like what does that mean like what
does it mean to talk to our customers
customer service yeah like no it's not
customer service you need to somehow
figure out a way to get in front of your
customers and I mean still it was
exhausting - what else was helpful yeah
just kind of like wrapping up I'm
curious we're about to start another
batch if you could give some advices
that people about to go into The
Bachelor you tell him I would say all
the suggestions and all the ideas matter
how crazy or off base or non-scalable or
hard that they may seem you just do it
at a hundred percent and and do it in an
exhaustive way that's what I would say
and I think the one thing I think that
that was I think the key for us really
getting a lot out of my see is that
every week we are partners were public
eye Kevin Hale those are our main
partners at the time and you know they
would have you know so you would sit in
the team in the group the group office
hours with all the other companies you
will see that you'll learn that you guys
are all in the same boat all have the
same problems and to some level or
extent
and you know and then they would give
you this feedback or ideas and then by
that following week you know we were
very diligent about having some
legitimate responses to everything that
they had said we should do and we just
really took that to heart so we just
like we like just ate it all up
but you know we really like Dovan 100%
and we weren't not above anything and I
think that that was really to our
benefit
what would you say yeah I think like we
took our learnings from corporate in
that way and so you know we had our
one-on-ones with the partners and we
created structure so like made sure we
set up the meetings every week because
it's up to you you don't have to set up
me and write them every week so we made
sure we had like reoccurring meetings
for the duration of the program and we
had goals or you know like here's our
agenda here's what we have questions
with and here's what we're looking to
get done yeah and they would have
suggestions and then the next week would
be like well here's the list of things
we got done and here's but you know we
held ourselves accountable and made
those meetings become to some extent
like the reason we're to hold us
accountable for them manage the men
exactly managed up to some extent yeah
and you know and like the the advisor
would give sometimes it's very specific
like you try you know I think there was
one like you need to have a blog for SEO
but sometimes it's just like you need to
talk to your customers and it's like
okay what does that mean and and try to
like figure that and distill it is is
also a big part of part of that as well
awesome well if people wanna try out app
go what do they do go to app deco com
apt Dec Oh calm thanks guys thank you
thank you so much
you